(gentle music)
- [Male] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain,
lone the master of
fire, tools and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly,
we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- And thank you,
it's a pleasure to be here
in this fabulous symposium.
I will be talking about mathematics
and mathematics is perhaps
one of the most abstract,
complex and precise human
conceptual systems ever invented.
Think about the Euclidean
point, for example.
It's an entity that has only one property,
that's location.
No extension whatsoever
so no Euclidean point exists
really objectively in the universe
and we have no biology to
perceive a Euclidean point.
Yet the Euclidean point,
the humble little guy,
is the cornerstone of the
edifice of Euclidean geometry
that led to analytic geometry,
non-Euclidean geometries,
differential geometries,
many other fields in mathematics.
So one area that we could look at
for the origins of this fabulous
human conceptual system,
this abstract thing, is number.
So to begin, consider the following.
If you're presented, let's say,
with this stimuli,
it's very easy for us to
discriminate between them.
But when the amount of dots increases,
it's not as easy
and we make a few more mistakes
and we make confusions.
Now the capacity to discriminate
when there's only few of
them is called subitizing
and has been studied by
experimental psychologists
in the 1940s.
So this is an ability we
don't need to go to school to
and we share with many other species.
Another ability is the following.
If we're presented, let's say, with
these groups of dots, black and white,
when their proportions differ considerably
it's very easy for us to say
which one has more,
even though we may not
know exactly how many
but we can tell.
When the proportions are
closer to each other,
it's a little harder and
sometimes very, very difficult.
So this capacity is referred to
as large quantity discrimination.
Now these two capacities we
share with many other species,
as I was saying.
So this has led to many,
really to believe that this
is about now mathematics.
So you will tend to see many papers
and chapters and academic material
talking about monkey
mathematical abilities
and kids in infancy without schooling
and arithmetic occurring
at a single neuron level
and so on and so forth
all the way to more recently number,
numerical cognition in
bees and other insects.
Now of course, this is academia
and then the media takes over
and says well like the
New York Times here,
science section earlier this year,
many animals can count,
some better than you.
And I know there's some
individuals in power now
who also say the New York
Times reporting fake news
these days.
But that's not the only one.
Sometimes we see animals with tools
and will kind of lead us to think
that there's some
mathematical content involved
or let's say this one,
Fish as Good as College
Students in Number Test,
and Mosquito Fish can Count up to 100
and count in quotes.
So the whole thing as a
package in this society,
there's kind of a widely
accepted view that says,
there's a biologically evolved
capacity that is specific
for number and arithmetic
and I will underline
here the word specific.
Now of course, the question
is is it really the case?
And it's been some debate more lately.
And part of the issue is
that some of these terms are policimous.
Like number we use it for passport number,
telephone number and many other things.
So what do we really mean by number?
And it turns out that in the literature,
the scientific literature,
is permeated really with
underspecified conceptions
of what is numbers
such that we can ascribe
numerical and arithmetical,
mathematical capacities
to many other species.
So let's examine this a little bit more.
If we leave aside non-human
animals for a moment,
we can focus on human data
that's been overlooked.
For example, all known languages
have natural quantifiers like
few, several, many and so on
but by no means, they all
exhibit exact quantification.
A recent study about 200
languages in aboriginal Australia
from 13 different linguistic families
showed that in fact,
almost 90% of these languages
do not have a numeral beyond
what we would call five.
So you can't, in cultures
speaking these languages,
refer to seven or 12 or 19 or 23.
Now similar research has been found
with hunter gatherers
in Australia and Africa
and South America
and I strongly recommend also
the book by Caleb Everett
that goes more in depth analyzing
these particular cultures.
Now the point is here
that when we look at human language,
language by itself really
does not lead to number
beyond the subitizing range.
So exact quantification
seems to be a cultural trait,
not a biological trait.
So how do we get from
perceiving, let's say these dots,
to labeling them as let's
say being nine or eight,
whether with spoken words or with digits?
Well when we do that,
we're involved in what is
called symbolic reference.
It's not just a purely
psychophysical perception anymore.
It's now another cognitive
activity like symbolic reference.
And we could do this with
many other types of numerals
like in Spanish nueve and ocho
or we could do Roman
numerals and other forms
and different bases in mathematics
or infinite decimal notation, if you like,
and so on and so forth.
And there's another important property.
It's their relational inoperable.
So like my laptop computer here says
number eight is equivalent to
the product of two and four,
it's one more than seven and those things.
So they're all related to each other.
So really our familiar
list, one, two, three,
has very specific abstract properties,
like it quantifies exactly,
not in an approximate way,
and it is abstract,
transcending stimulus modality,
visual or auditory,
it has a cardinal sense, an ordinal sense,
a relational property that we just saw,
combinative, operable,
and most importantly,
referred to symbolically.
So the number really is exact
symbolic quantification.
And this seems to be quite different
from what we observe,
let's say with trained,
by humans of course,
trained animals in the lab
where you can get, for example, monkeys
in painstaking training,
four months, 20,000 trials,
to discriminate dots in
a ratio three to four
only to 70% of accuracy.
So it seems to be that we're
in a different realm here.
So to summarize here,
we can look at this figure.
Essentially what we have
is amount of discrete
stuff, let's say dots,
going from center to periphery,
increasing in amount.
So what you see in the bottom left here,
what you have is subitizing a
large quantity discrimination,
the two abilities we just exercised
a little bit at the beginning,
and we share those with many species.
Now with symbolic reference,
there's a symbolic gap there,
we can then label things
like natural quantifiers
like many, few and so on,
and then with exact quantification
we get into what you see
clockwise there in blue
which is now truly numerical.
So the point is here,
what you see on the left
is really about quantity perception.
It's quantical abilities that we,
it's biologically endowed.
But in order to really get to number
we need to go across
the symbolic reference
and that is not biologically evolvable.
So here I'm gonna borrow
a quote from Terri Deacon,
also a member of Carta,
who says, "Symbolic reference
must be acquired by learning,"
so this occurs in the
anthology of individuals,
"and lacks both the natural associations
"and transgenerational
reproductive consequences
"that would make such references
"biologically evolvable."
So exact symbolic quantification
beyond the subitizing range
really needs a whole apparatus,
a culture that actually cares
about being exact and precise.
So motivated by cultural preoccupations,
tracking valuables, trading,
accounting and so on.
And this supported by
and enhanced by tools
and off-loading cognition
which requires enculturation.
Of course, part of that comes
and we heard already
previously about this,
the invention of writing
about 6,000 years ago.
Initially, according to many authors
coming from tokens,
tokens printed on envelope of clay
and eventually leading to clay tablets.
But you could also have,
in the absence of writing, for example,
like the Inca did with
the use of the apos,
doing performing amazingly
sophisticated calculations
without writing
or what you see in Oceania,
in Papua New Guinea,
many groups, you have
now grammatical tools
in the language that
could for example codify
certain types of morphines
that would characterize
number of quantities
for counting things you care about.
For example, in this case,
as you see in the picture,
yams in the culture Nen,
work done by Nick Evans.
So what's in common there
is that you need a
conventionalized symbolic reference
for exact quantification.
Now when there is number,
most number systems are in base five or 10
and you would say, "Why is that?"
Well, here we have a very handy tool
all of a sudden in front of us,
you can identify fingers
and we can sort of,
they're readily available.
So that could explain part of it.
The issue is that gorillas, chimpanzees
and many species, raccoons,
they also are pentadactyl,
they also have five fingers.
So evolution there,
giving that particular form.
So we have that,
we have brains that control
and get all the inputs, et cetera,
but what we don't have in these cases,
is symbolic reference
and the capacity to actually use this
as now potential tools
which doesn't come with a handbook.
Cultural variations exist
in how you actually use
the hand for counting.
So here you have top right number eight,
being characterized by
manually, unimanually,
sometimes using the finger,
sometimes using the finger joints.
So number eight, if you use finger joints
and the tip would be this,
for example, and so on
in some cultures.
Now, when there is written
exact symbolic number,
it seems all this to be mediated
by culturally shaped cortical,
phenotypical plasticity.
According to this work by
Tang et. al, for example,
they presented digits to English speakers
and Chinese native speakers
and they just asked
to do very simple calculations.
And what we observe is
very different recruitment
for neural populations in the two groups.
You see more recruitment
in the left hemisphere
(mumbles) area in the English speakers,
and much, let's say, more
in the premotor regions
for the Chinese speakers.
So number then,
really what we have,
is a language-mediated,
conventionalized, exact
symbolic quantification
which is a cultural trait.
And this occurrying quite, quite recently
and largely outside of
biological evolution.
So it builds on biologically
evolved preconditions.
We need subitizing and large
quantity discrimination
but themselves, they're not
mathematical or numerical.
So these are motivated by
cultural preoccupations,
as I said,
supported crucially by
material and conceptual tools
and the biology that makes
enculturation possible.
So I want to take this
now to the next step.
Once we have numbers,
we can start creating all
kinds of other things.
One very ubiquitous, powerful
tool is a number line
which now we need another system
which is to conceive numbers
as locations in space,
metaphorically, if you will.
And this of course,
many of the talks before this,
when we're using graphs to characterize
some mounds and so on,
it's helpful for reading economic graphs
and look at scientific data
or develop vector spaces
and fancy visualizations and so on.
What is interesting
is that these days,
this is learned or
presented in kindergarten.
So kindergarteners already
start to see little bunnies
jumping back and forth and froggies
doing jumps and so on and so forth.
So this has led a lot of people
to think that perhaps we have,
again, a biologically
endowed mental number line
which is housed in the
intraparietal sulcus
of the human brain.
Well that's true if you
only look at westerners
who already went to school
and have done all this work.
So a lot of papers support the idea
that you would have very
spontaneous mappings
and occurring in infants and macaques
and more recently a paper in Science
saying that newborn chicks now,
so go figure, what kind
of cortex they would have,
would actually have a mental
number line like humans.
Now if that were really the case,
let's cross that with
some other type of data.
For example, we would expect culture,
number-savvy cultures
like Babylonia, let's say,
to have some manifestation
of number lines somewhere
in all the number crunching they did.
Well, when you look at
half a million tablets
that we know today,
there's not a single number line there.
So that says something.
They did a lot of numbers
without a number line.
In fact, you have to go to 17th century,
it's not even in La
Geometrie by Rene Descartes
who invented analytic geometry,
not a single number line there either.
There first appears to be,
John Napier when he's
introducing algorithms,
a very sophisticated notion
and he is saying, okay, here's a line,
we're gonna start thinking this way.
But the first who does the
operational use of a number line
is John Wallis.
And here, if you really
look at the text it says,
okay, the audience is
(speaking in foreign language),
the top of the top of mathematicians
in Europe in the 17th century saying,
think of a man walking five steps
and then walking two back
and that's gonna be five
minus two equals three.
That's what you hear today
in a kindergarten class
but this is now a few
hundred years ago in Europe.
So we also wanted to test
how spontaneous is this?
So we went, we did a study
among the Yupno of Papua New Guinea,
and we presented a line segment
and following other methods
that have been used in the Amazon,
and we could see that for example,
even though they had
numbers to at least 20,
and numerals,
they essentially mapped
small numbers on one end
and bigger to the other end,
whether it was dots or
tones or other things
unlike the schooled Yupno
and California controls.
As you can see, on the right side.
So the red one being the unschooled
using only the extremes.
So no use of the path whatsoever
which is required for the number lines.
So the intrusion doesn't seem to be,
again, universal in that sense.
So what do we do with these abstractions?
Well, we do crazy things.
So of course, we have the mathematicians
very recently developing it
but today is introduced
in the kindergarten class.
But this could be taken
to further directions
to develop the notions of hyperreal lines.
So all of a sudden now,
the number line and the real line
which is now housing irrational numbers
and rational numbers
and by virtue of least upper bound axon,
you have a complete order field,
no more thoughts could fit in there.
Well you can when you go
to non Euclidean umbers.
Infinitely, tiny,
infinitely small numbers,
the absolons you see there,
or huge numbers, their
reciprocals, the omegas,
that are bigger and larger
than any real number.
So then you start to have embedded,
mutually incompatible, non-commensurable,
number lines embedded
in infinitely many spots
in infinitely many of these lines.
All this going back to
the simple number line
that we develop about 300 years ago.
So really the story of numbers
and tools and mathematics
can be reduced to this
process of enculturation
where you do need an
a biological apparatus
that would support it.
So I would like to close with this quote,
and I thank Pascal Gagneur
for pointing me to this one,
by geneticist and evolutionary biologist,
Theodosius Dobzhansky who said,
"Human evolution has two components,
"the biological or organic,
"and the cultural or superorganic.
"These components are
neither mutually exclusive
"nor independent
"but interrelated and interdependent.
"Human evolution cannot be understood
"as a purely biological process,
"nor can it be adequately described
"as a history of culture.
"It is the interaction
of biology and culture."
And I think mathematics
exemplifies this perfectly well.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- So I'd like you to raise your hand
if someone in your life,
a young person in your
life, often looks like this.
So maybe it's a child, a grandchild,
the person in the line for
coffee in front of you.
Okay, you are not alone.
Meet this generation of digital natives.
Right, so we've heard that term,
a generation of young people
that were born without knowing
a time before the internet.
So I'm a digital immigrant.
I won't ask you to identify
if you are or not
but I remember a world
without the internet
and having to learn how to
integrate the digital world
into how I work, how I communicate,
and that's a very different space
than our kids are growing up in now.
So in the digital age,
the one thing we do know
is that the young people among us
are early adopters,
they are enthusiastic
adopters of new technologies.
Here's some data just from 2004.
We started following kids
around on their mobile devices
around 2007
and this just shows you
some of the changes we saw
during that time.
2018 is a last time for which we have
a representative sample
and 95% of adolescents now
have access to a mobile device.
They're on them quite a lot.
And so a recent survey showed us
that tweens, those are
eight to 12 year olds,
they're on 4.36 hours,
and this is just for media screen time.
So this doesn't count
screen time for homework
or other activities.
Teens, it's 6.4 hours a day,
so almost six and a half hours a day.
And I want you to hold
the number in your mind,
that's the three hours more per day
that children from low-income
households are on a screen.
So there's a huge
difference in screen time
based on the income level of your family.
So we have a sample
of 2,000 young adolescents
we've been following
and these are some data on them.
This is just them across age.
So on the bottom of the screen,
you'll see age here from 11 to 15
and you'll see if the
young people in your life
are around 11 years old,
about 48% of their peers
own a mobile device.
As we get older in our sample,
we get up here to almost full saturation.
This line up here is access
to the internet at home.
So something we used to worry
a lot about in education
was a digital divide.
So some kids not having
access to the internet,
that's no longer true.
And smartphone use is actually higher
among children from lower income families.
So we don't see that
traditional digital divide.
We see few differences in
mobile device ownership
by socioeconomic status
but as I'm gonna show you,
we see differences in
experiences and maybe effects.
So what does this all mean?
If you pick up a paper,
probably today or tomorrow,
you'll read some story
about how digital devices
are ruining our children,
smartphones are destroying a generation.
Recently we had a number of psychologists
sign a letter, an open letter to Apple,
demanding that tech companies
end their addictive
practices toward our children
based on evidence, they said,
that smartphones were
making our children lonely,
depressed, suicidal,
stealing things from them.
These are big claims,
these are big claims.
So is this constant connection,
is it harmful to our kids?
And I'm gonna show you
two pieces of evidence.
The first one is from a team in Britain
and they've assembled
large amasses of data
on hundreds of thousands of adolescents.
Now these are surveys,
so just correlational research
asking kids to report
on the amount of time
they're on their devices and
their mental health problems.
I'm gonna show you a graph here
but the thing to focus on
is just this pattern, a
Goldilocks effect, right?
So here are the kids that
are not on screen time
at all in a day.
Here are the kids in
those one or two hours
and then here's kind of a
deterioration of wellbeing
across time.
So described as a Goldilocks effect,
the kids that are on not at all,
don't look so great on mental health,
the kids in the one to
two hour range look good
and then out at the lower ends of the tail
or the higher ends of the tail,
those kids are experiencing some problems.
Now remember, this is correlational.
The other thing to remember
is that these data
and all the data that are presented,
including the data where people
argue that smartphones are
causing mental health problems,
these actually explain
less than one percent
of the differences between
kids and their mental health.
So said another way,
99.5% of the reasons that kids
are different than each other
on their mental health problems
is due to something
other than screen time.
These same authors
took other variables they
measured in the data chips,
oh chips, in the data,
including potato chips,
eating potato chips,
higher correlation than screen time,
eating breakfast, 14 times
higher than screen time.
So just a word of caution.
Now we took a different approach.
We've been following kids on their phone.
So we had the advantage
of not necessarily comparing
kids to each other.
So a kid who's on zero hours a day
and a kid who's on five hours a day,
they look very different on
things other than screen time.
Their parents probably have them
in a very different
structured environment,
lots of things are different.
So we looked and followed
the same kids over time
and asked the question,
on days when Sally is using screens a lot,
what does her cognition look like,
what does her mental health look like,
what does her sleep look like
on days when she's using less?
So we use her as her own control.
This is a study done by Michey Jensen,
one of my postdocs
and this is in North Carolina,
this is the state of North Carolina.
Each one of those red dots
is where a family in our
study lives of the 2,000 kids
and 400 of those kids
we followed intensively on their phones.
So every day, they're reporting to us
on how much they're using their devices,
their mental health, et cetera.
And we find very few associations
between how much they're
using, their mental health.
And where we do find signal
is actually in the opposite direction.
So days that they're
more closely connected
to their friends and family online
are days that they're
less lonely and depressed.
But again, really small effects.
We've been interested in this.
We've been using digital
technology and mobile phones
as a tool to study
adolescent's mental health
and when we first started in this area,
parents were asking for advice.
It's scary.
It's scary to have an adolescent, period.
It's scary to have them glued
to their phone all the time.
And so what we wanted to
dig a little deeper in
was what are the fears that parents have
and what's the science?
What do we really know
and then what's the narrative?
So we went through and we identified
these seven fears that
parents and adults have
when they see young people
walking around on their devices.
And then we went to the
scientific literature
and we started to examine
what do we actually
know about the effects.
And here, I won't have time
to go into them all today
but I'll just summarize
with a couple of messages.
In most cases we found mixed
results, we need more data.
But in the majority of cases,
we actually found evidence
for positive effects.
So kids that were the
most connected online
were also most connected offline.
If there were signs of vulnerability,
bullying, et cetera, offline,
those kids were also
experiencing problems online.
So it was a bit of a mirror
between online and offline life.
Parent time,
so it was displacing time
you'd spend with parents,
but it wasn't impacting the relationship.
Where we do find some negative effects
is in multitasking.
So Paolo mentioned that before,
we need to keep our eye on that
and sleep is critically important.
So there is no question
that being on your phone late at night
which many kids are, is impairing
sleep in important ways.
But when we publish these results
people were angry.
Parents were angry at us.
We were saying
that there are these things
that are happening with our kids,
there are things that we worry about
but we don't think the
phone is the problem.
And this wasn't a popular message
and in the discussion section,
you guys can yell at me then,
I'm used to it now.
I wasn't ready for it here
but I'm ready now.
And so what we asked
is what are the risks?
What are the risk of assuming
that phones are to blame
for these really important
problems facing our kids
versus taking a more holistic view?
Now Paolo did a wonderful job
of asking this question
of rewiring the brain
and Leah showed us signs
of developmental plasticity
in the brain.
And this has been the focus of
extreme attention right now.
So headlines, are smartphones
rewiring the brain?
And again, this isn't a new concern,
whether tools are impacting
the brain in some way.
This is from the New York Times in 1904.
Concern that these race car drivers
might have a different brain.
We've seen concern.
We see fears about new technologies.
We saw this with writing,
people starting to write.
This is gonna impair our
ability to remember things
with kids, with kids.
We've seen this with numerous things.
We've seen it with the
introduction of romance novels,
the introduction of public libraries,
rock and roll,
things that kids are doing we don't like.
My husband started to complain
about this and I said,
"Stop complaining because
I think this means
"that we're not kids anymore."
Kids these days.
So this is Scientific American,
"Are Smartphones Really
Destroying the Adolescent Brain?"
And I think that this
is an important question
of how the brain has become rewired,
how we're learning language
differently, et cetera.
There's a recent article that showed,
in fact, digital technology
use and thumb movement
can be traced, differences
in this on a day to day level
to cortical activity based on an EEG
and those are important questions
but I think maybe they're
the wrong ones right now
if we're thinking about
our kid's wellbeing.
I think the questions
that we need to be asking
are how are these tools used,
how are we scaffolding
and how are we engaging
with these new technologies
with our kids and optimizing them
for their potential and their future?
So we wrote recently that smartphones,
they might be bad for some teens,
but not for all
and if you take you back
to that initial data that I showed you,
children in low income households
spending on average three more
hours a day on their phone
than kids in more affluent households,
it's not just a time difference,
it's what you're doing online.
So higher income households,
more likely to be using
digital technologies
for educational purposes,
looking up information.
Lower income households,
less parental involvement, less
adult involvement on average
in scaffolding those behaviors
and building digital literacy
and the other things that we
know our kids are gonna need
if the future is in fact digital.
In our study we found
that children in disadvantaged households,
they actually experienced more
spillover from social media.
So something that happens on social media
actually they report results
in an offline problem,
a fight, an argument, trouble at school.
So it might not just be
different experiences,
it might be different effects
for kids that are the most vulnerable.
So as we look into the future,
it's really not so much
about the effect of the tool,
the access to these tools is equaling out.
Kids have access to computers,
kids have access to smartphones
across socioeconomic status
but the types of experiences
they're having online,
the type of help that they're getting
to ensure that they build
the skills in an online world
for an online future
are very different
and it's possible that there
might be more negative effects
for certain populations of children.
So I would encourage us
as we kind of look towards
supporting children in the digital world
that we look past some of the headlines,
some of the fears that we have,
some of the reasons that we don't like
the technology itself
and for parents who
report the biggest sources
of conflict in their home
is fights over how long
their kid is on a device,
and I screamed at my
child yesterday for this
and caught myself.
So instead of focusing on the time limits,
focus on what they're doing.
Take some time,
spend some time with them there.
And we're entering into a whole new world
as our homes get smarter.
So here's a little boy
talking to his Alexa
and I'm sure we'll have
a lively discussion
of what it means to have Alexa
raising our children soon.
So thank you for your attention
and for the opportunity.
(audience applause)
- Alright, so to address this question
of the impact of tool use and technology
on the evolution of the human mind,
I want to begin by
addressing this question,
how can we account for our species'
immense ecological dominance
and our stunning technological prowess?
Now when people approach this question
they come to it with certain intuitions.
Intuitions that we're smart,
we're good at building causal models
of how the world works,
we're good at individually figuring out
and this must be the
secret of our success.
But it turns out that
that's not the best story
and that we're actually not that good
at figuring things out.
And so what I'm gonna
try to convince you today
is that in fact, there's
another way of approaching this
and there's a different explanation
for the secret of our success.
Okay, so I'm gonna just begin
with a little bit of data.
So this comes from a
battery of cognitive tests
administered to three different species.
So two and a half year old humans,
chimpanzees and orangutans,
and this research is done by Esther Herman
and Mike Tomasello
at the Max Planck Institute
for Evolutionary Anthropology.
And so 18 different cognitive tests
broken down into three different areas.
So space, a subset of tests on space,
quantities, causality and social learning.
And what you can see from this figure here
is that the humans do about
as well as the chimps,
they get about 70% right on this space.
The chimps actually do
sightly better than humans
on quantity.
So its within the margin of error
but the chimps do a little bit better.
And same thing on causality,
the chimps do marginally better.
Now if you dig into the causality test
and look specifically at the tests
that try to measure
differences in tool using,
the chimps actually do
much better on tool using
than the two and a half year old children.
Now I think the real telling point here
is that if I were to give
this battery of cognitive
tests to you guys,
you would blow the roof off the test
and you'd do much better than the apes.
So between two and going
up well into the 20s,
humans still,
we get better and better
at solving these cognitive problems.
So something is happening
during that time.
Meanwhile, if we look at the chimpanzees,
there's no change over
the course of their lives.
In fact, sometimes the young chimpanzees,
the five year old chimpanzees
are better at the tasks
than the older chimpanzees.
So that's a hint to what
must be going on there.
There's nothing special
about these particular measures.
I could show you data on working memory
or chimps and humans engaging
in strategic thinking
and you would see that
there's no particular
human advantage in this.
Another way of getting at this
would be to think about
taking this room of very smart people
and parachuting you into the Ituri Forest
or into the Amazon basin,
and having you try to survive.
And you would no doubt struggle,
you couldn't start a fire,
you couldn't make tools,
if it was a game of Survivor,
you would probably lose
to Dorothy's capuchins.
So we're clearly missing something.
Humans rely on this large
body of cultural inheritance.
So it's not our innate intelligence
or our problem solving abilities
or our ability to build
causal models on the fly
but something else.
So where do our fancy tools
and technologies come from?
So I'm gonna make the case
that it comes from our collective brain,
and particularly, our collective brain
is anchored in our cultural
natures and social natures.
So these are two separate things.
Our cultural natures is our
ability to learn from others,
to look out into the minds and behaviors
of others in our social milieu
and filter out and learn ideas,
beliefs, values, practices,
from other members of our group.
The social part is that
for various reasons,
we're able to live in large groups
and the larger the group, the better,
the more we're able to
generate ideas, beliefs
and values that are adapted
to our environments,
more sophisticated technologies.
Alright, now to get at this question
from an evolutionary perspective,
this approach was actually
Marcus Feldman led us off today
and in 1976 he wrote a paper
with Luigi Luca Cavalli-Sforza
in which they made the first effort
to take the logic of natural selection
and of genetic evolution
and to think about how it might've shaped
our psychology for cultural learning,
our abilities to adaptively extract
ideas, beliefs and values
from other members of our social group.
others like Boyd and Richardson
went to build a large research
program on that process.
And since then,
there's been a great deal of research,
much a bit with young children
showing that from even before age one,
we keenly attend to who we learn from.
So we learn from certain individuals
or particular about what we learn from,
how we integrate information
across individuals
and when we choose to use social learning
over our own intuitions
or our own experience.
And together when you
put all this together
in large groups over many generations,
it produces what I call
cultural adaptations.
And this includes the fancy
tools and technologies
that we're so impressive
for in the natural world.
Now this process can and often does
operate outside of conscious awareness.
Now one of my favorite things to do
is to regale people
with many, many examples
of all the ways in
which cultural evolution
builds adaptive behaviors
in ways that are unconscious
and unseen behind the scenes.
I'll just give you one example today.
It's something you're already
familiar with, spices.
So people use spices in different ways,
different cultures have
different spicing traditions,
some places use many more
spices in the recipes
than other places.
But once you realize that spices
are an adaptation to the
problem of food-borne pathogens,
you can predict a whole bunch of things
about the kinds of plants
for which we'll harvest
their chemical properties
and put them in our foods,
which societies will tend
to use a lot of spices,
which spices they'll use
and how they'll recombine
spices in synergetic ways
that make it more powerful
and more antimicrobial
and you can predict which kinds of foods.
And this can all happen
outside of conscious awareness.
Many of you probably didn't know
that spicing was a protectant
against foodborne pathogens.
And in some cases, it's
even possible to show
that if people understood,
they might be less
likely to do the behavior
and it would be maladaptive.
So understanding is a
bad thing in some cases.
Now when you begin to build models
and think about how humans learn,
so we take what we know
about human learning
and we allow humans to learn in groups,
interconnected in different ways,
one of the robust findings
from what is now a
decent body of literature
is that larger and more
interconnected populations
evolve technologies and tools
and other aspects of culture more quickly
at adapting to their environment
and their ability to hold and preserve
large bodies of different
tools and technologies
is bigger, is more,
they can hold more than
in larger populations.
Even more interesting,
and something that you can
use to solve various puzzles
throughout human history
and around the world
is that a sudden reduction
in the size of a population
will cause populations
to ebb away technology,
to lose things over time.
Now one piece of evidence
that I like for this
is research done by Michelle
Klein and Robert Boyd
and what these anthropologists did
is they went back to the ethnography
from societies all over Polynesia
and they coded marine foraging technology.
And they counted the number of tools
these different islands
around the Pacific had
and they also assessed the complexity.
And you can see here,
this is an example of
how very simple method
developed by Wendell Oswald
in which you just count
the parts and the tool
and you can get a number of
techno units for that tool.
Show you the results here quickly.
So in this plot here on this side,
you can see this is the population size,
it's a log scale.
These dots are the different islands
and this is the number of tools.
So larger islands
had more different kinds of
tools for marine foraging
and this is the mean
number of techno units.
So not only did larger
islands have more total tools,
those tools were on average more complex,
they had more parts.
You can see that they also
differentiated by contact.
So in addition to the population size,
they got a measure of how
connected the islands were.
And islands that had more
contact with other islands
in the Pacific were,
they're above the line,
which means that they have an extra boost
over and above their population size
from the interconnectedness,
from being a little
bit more interconnected
with other populations.
And one thing that's interesting
from the point of view of looking back
at the paleoanthropological record
is it's not an uncommon practice
to try to infer things about the cognition
of ancient creatures
based on the kind of tools they make.
But if you were to use
that same approach here,
you would deduce
that the folks who lived
in Hawaii traditionally
were much smarter and more
mentally sophisticated
than the folks who lived
in the small island
off the coast of New Guinea.
The lesson here is that it's
really the collective brain
that's doing work,
not the individual smarts
of the people in the brain.
Incidentally,
this is part of the Austroasian expansion
so it's relatively recent.
We can be confident there aren't
genetic differences there.
Alright, now I don't want you to think
that this is just interesting
for thinking about ancient
Polynesian societies.
So I put in this plot
which is US cities
and the number of innovations they produce
based on patent data.
So the larger the US city, over 10,000,
the more patents they produce.
That's not too interesting
in that we would expect larger cities
to have more people to
produce more patents,
but this is a super linear relationship
which means controlling for things
like education and occupation,
the same person put into a larger city
is more likely to produce
patents and innovations.
So the people get more
innovative in larger cities.
There's a number of data sets
showing this same relationship.
Okay, now those are all
interesting correlations
but we can't be too confident
there's actually a causal relationship.
So what researchers have done
is to go to the laboratory
and try to create microsocieties
which allow us to get some insights.
So the typical microsociety
that's been used by a number
of different researchers
is to take a bunch of,
say 100 undergraduates,
and create generations.
So each individual gets a task
that they have to solve,
they do their best on the task.
My tradition likes to pay
people for right answers.
And then they transmit the
information in some way
down to another generation
of undergraduates,
laboratory generation,
who then takes that information,
does their best, and passes it down.
So we're gonna run this
for 10 generations.
Now the key thing in this set up
is that in the individual condition,
you can only learn from one teacher,
so not much interconnectedness.
In this condition,
you could learn from any one of the five
in the prior generation.
So you could potentially recombine ideas
from different individuals.
They had to replicate this image
with a notoriously user
unfriendly image editing program
and they had a time limit.
As I mentioned,
they were paid for their performance
but they're also incentivized
for their student's performance.
So they get more money if
they send good instructions
which then after the task,
they can write up to two pages
which goes down to the next generation.
It allows us to analyze the
kinds of things people said.
And then so in the next generation,
everybody after generation one,
they get the model's product,
which they can compare
to the target image,
this image,
and they get the write-up
and then they have a go
at the task themselves.
This is the results.
So 10 generations.
You can see here in generation one,
they actually had a pretty good group
of the single learning tradition group.
But in the more interconnected group,
they didn't have such a lucky first group.
But here, a cumulative
cultural evolutionary process
kicked in
where they could take from
the previous generation,
they could add to it,
any lucky insights were brought together
and then passed down.
So that by the end,
the 10th generation is twice as skilled
as the 10th generation
in the other treatment.
Not only that,
if you break down and look
at the data individually,
the worst person in the
interconnected population,
so the population that
could learn from others
is better than the best person
in the single population
where you just have one to one learning.
So it makes a big difference
in how apparently smart people look.
It looks like they can
just do things better.
Alright,
so I want to get back to the question
that I began at the beginning
when I introduced the apes and the humans.
And this was the idea
that so something from going
from a two and a half year old
when your cognition is
not that much better
than a chimpanzee,
till you're 20 something
when you can blow the roof off
the test, what happens there?
And part of what's going on here
is a download of prebuilt solutions
that have accumulated
in our inherited body
of know-how over many generations.
So simple things like springs and screws
and levers and pulleys
are hard to invent for the first time
but once you grow up in an environment
that has springs and screws
and levers and pulleys,
they're easy to figure out
and then reapply to new contexts.
One example that I like is the wheel.
It seems relatively simple.
You see Gary Larson cartoons
with ancient human ancestors
experimenting with wheels.
But actually, the wheel
arrives relatively late
in human history,
about 6,000 years ago.
It appears on carts and then pottery,
eventually it's used to transfer power
but only in Eurasia
and doesn't appear in the
North America, South America,
Oceania, Australia.
So they don't invent wheels.
Sometimes people have pointed
to certain kinds of animals being present
but the dog's everywhere.
And you can see the Belgians here
are using this dog to pull their cart.
So there's at least some kind
of animals that can pull.
And then once you have wheels,
you can do all kinds of things with them.
Elastically stored energy,
used to make a bow and arrow,
never invented in Australia,
you don't see anything with
elastically stored energy.
Fletching is not invented in New Guinea,
although New Guinea folks
do have bows and arrows.
We heard from Rafael about
the counting systems.
So lots of societies like the
Machiguenga who I worked with
count one, two, three, many.
This group counts to 27.
You can see Rafael and I
read the same literature.
And you can find everything in between.
So you can find groups that
can count to 11, 13, 36,
some groups figure out how to cycle
but you guys have all been
bequeathed a counting system
that allows you to count without bound.
Another example is the number zero.
So the number zero that has a placeholder
has only been invented
twice in human history,
once by the Mayans,
and a second time in India.
It diffuses to Europe
through Islamic societies.
My favorite example is the abacus.
So you can track the
evolution of the abacus
from Babylonian counting boards
and you can see how the
abacus is evolving culturally
to take use of how we use
space and how we clump things
in order to exploit aspects
of our evolved cognition.
But then what's amazing to me
is that children can train on the abacus,
the physical device,
and with sufficient training,
they can put the abacus aside.
And then you can give
them incredibly complex
calculation problems
where they're adding up large numbers,
10 or 15 of them,
and they do it, you can
see their fingers moving
and they're not touching anything physical
and they seem to be looking up in the air
and then suddenly they
come out with the answer.
And they have races
between the mental abacus
and the calculator.
So this is a whole new cognitive ability
that's kind of bootstrapped up
from this physical apparatus
which evolved culturally
to fit aspects of our minds.
Alright, and so this gives
us a different picture
of how humans have evolved.
So culture-driven genetic evolution.
Sometime in our species'
evolutionary history,
I think it happened actually
before about two million years ago,
we became a species with
cumulative cultural evolution.
What we passed down from one generation
was built upon by the next generation.
How this happened,
if you want to know that
you'll have to read my book,
The Secret of Our Success.
I actually favor a kind
of social explanation.
So if we became more social
and had larger groups,
that could push a group of primates
across this threshold,
what I call the rubicon.
And this leads to ongoing
cultural evolution.
Now of course, genetic
evolution doesn't stop
and hasn't stopped now.
So we have two parallel
inheritance systems
and these inheritance systems
have been interacting over
millions of years potentially,
or at least hundreds of thousands.
So you can produce
things like stone tools,
like Dietrich told us about,
that allow you to process food
and reduce the selection
pressure on your teeth
and your chewing apparatus.
It can produce things
like fire and cooking
which allows us to externalize
our digestive system
and shrink our colon, shrink our stomachs.
It supplies energy to allow
us to have larger brains,
it gives us extra dexterity in our hands
to use those tools
and in particular, in this world,
our brains are being
selected for their ability
to acquire, organize, store
and retransmit cultural information.
We're cultural learners
because the more our brains get better
at doing this culture thing,
the more cumulative cultural
evolution is gonna create
things that we need to learn.
So now the game is all the
valuable stuff I need to know
is in the minds of the prior generation.
And if I can learn something from him
and something from him
and something from her,
then I can recombine them
and have an even better
cultural repertoire.
So things like throwing and
finding tubers underground,
water containers can allow us
to engage in long distance running
and persistence hunting.
This is gonna create a pressure
for even larger brains
to learn all those tools and technologies,
clothings and adhesives,
eventually projectiles.
And this can explain why we have a,
why we seem to have a
specialized cognition
for learning about artifacts.
And we regard and learn about
those in a different way
than we learn about things
in the biological world,
so plants and animals.
And in particular,
it helps explain why
we're willing to put faith
in the wisdom of prior generations.
Developmental psychologists
call this over-imitation,
why we copy all the steps.
But it also explains
why we might be willing
to believe in invisible beings
or other magical powers.
There's a lot of wisdom in the tradition
and we can't always tell what
the useful information is
from the not so useful information.
So the key to understanding humans
is to recognize this long term
period of dual inheritance
and that's it.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)